un jour la vie 20 à déserter la terre
et les ténèbres nos plongèrent
au fond de la vis
stephen hawking disait
dans le futur si l'espèce humaine veut
survivre elle devra quitter la planète
terre
[Musique]
à des années lumière de notre monde
nous allons créer un nouveau foyer pour
l'humanité
un exode vers la terre promise
[Musique]
la planète est réuni toutes les
conditions pour abriter la vie
préparez vous au choc
les cartes stellaire elle ne correspond
pas nous ne sommes pas sur tech
objet non identifié en approche
vous ne pouvez pas rester ici
devons aller au cours de la mission
évacué rebbah tués
ils nouvelle page de notre histoire
commence ici
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
occultant
iris genies à y
croire
bref kia mal
abete indienne us à chantepie nouveautés
et une herse
et mes côtés la
saison nicolas galliano fillion samedi
l'un des phares et la barmaid three days
[Musique]
higuain
si cet event rôle et ses stocks à perdre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une
[Musique]
année
ma femme
[Musique]
émission
cartes
[Musique]
m
je tourne
à
suivre intel pour akalé l'oni la poudre
d'hibiscus ça va donner de l'acidité
on va rester sur le balsamique vous
faites partie de ma brigade vous vous
pliez amérique et ils ont aimé au pain
c'est pas ma question à 6 c'est la
question qu'on doit se poser quand on
est chef excusez moi c'est bon on a beau
jouer casse et du boulot dit passer en
un mois qui n'avait d'un état kart wii
salut c-46 baril à l'appareil balaci qui
me rappelle alors
je cherche lorenzo cardy c'est pour le
poste de chef de cuisine le restaurant
du coup le lieu de charme à monsieur est
ici cet employé c'est à dire ce sont des
jeunes mineurs en attente de papiers les
migrants on a un peut extrapoler
gervinho file c'est à le moindre
problème plutôt qu'à ma porte bonne nuit
alors tu m'entends que je crie comme ça
ah non à peine
et quel enfer vous avez vu l'état la
cuisine moi je peux pas tenir les
horaires pour 70 personnes seules si
vous avez besoin d'être demandé aux
jeunes ici n'attendent que ça
enfin c'est pas possible ils sont
combien sa vie ils sont très motivés
vous avez des planches et des icônes
sommes là c'est quoi le chrono ne savent
rien faire bah oui
c'est cucul c'est la tête et ça compte
de ta corps c'est quoi ça ça c'est stylé
mais non c'est parce qu'ils essaient
cradat
je me fastidieux pour devenir chef
france gall et galeux compliqué devant
moi ton tataki de vaud la locloise et
des semaines entre la terre et la mer
éclate sérieux pas les arrondis la mise
en bouche j'ai rien compris
c'est magnifique ça non
[Musique]
comment ça se passe a plongé fois tu 10
h f
ça
va tourner je sens qu'avec londres
faux
[Musique]
la scion est mon
anticipation fait notre dame le ton
amoureux ça va le parti de partout les
officiels les politiques et célébrités
on va voir deux feux à gérer il va
falloir au patois quelques-uns baril est
bloqué
voiture
en suivant reconnaissance c'est pas bon
allez on y va
ça veut dire désastre annoncé
[Musique]
si on peut monter avec quelques gars au
grand complet avec mon général avec mes
hommes on se porte volontaire
[Musique]
les heures supplémentaires et du renfort
45 enfants
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce hacker ils appellent ça la
chambre froide bon voilà ça c'est ton
arme
[Musique]
tu as déjà travaillé dans une marque
c'est mon premier jour
t'en fais pas avec le temps tu vas t'y
habituer
[Musique]
mais monsieur
car toute la connard
allo
[Musique]